because there's always the port there's
always that picture where you're like
hmm this is this is a 50/50 am I gonna
see titty or this just an itchy picture
you know I mean I'm not gonna see like
the facial expression isn't like it
isn't like ah hey girl it's like a it's
like it's just like a slightly blushing
picture like blushing features she like
this could be just a really nice piece
of artwork or it could just be someone
getting dicks from behind I don't know I
have to click to find out like this
photo of like a woman who was in a
Naruto cause it was heavily crop so I
could see was like oh [ __ ] was Tsunade
it's not how I found it was a rebel
house Dee Dissidia likes it I thought I
thought I saw the top half and I thought
well that's a good look like no one
we're all sitting in the living room
right yeah that Sydney barges in is like
come on what the [ __ ] you like so we go
and we expand this image and like 70% of
it is her with her pose she was doing it
was like it was like top half like this
the bottom half was just one man's like
wait what so here's an open oh [ __ ] I
was laughing about that for like a week
yeah I'm gonna find the photo it says
yeah